the authorities arrest the alleged mail
bomber the media demonstrate they have
no intention of abandoning their biases
and we check the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so I apologize for uh starting late
today obviously there's a lot of
breaking news and I'm going to give you
all of the updates plus the predictable
media reaction and why I was right and
everybody else is wrong because I mean
that's what we do here we'll get to all
of that in just a second first let me
remind you that you should not miss the
latest episode of Andrew Klavan another
Kingdom performed by Michael Mills who
is in fact execrable but his performance
is not today we'll be live-streaming the
first 15 minutes of episode 4 titled
worst homecoming ever which could also
be the name of today's show head on over
to daily wire comm and subscribe to
watch the full episode and get early
access to upcoming episodes every Monday
go check that out right now also before
we begin let me remind you that we are
all mortal and because we're all mortal
you owe it to yourself to get some life
insurance life insurance is super
important but if you haven't actually
gotten life insurance now is the time
for you to do it because it's actually
irresponsible if something should happen
to you your family should be taken care
of and this is why you mean policy
genius they compare quotes from the top
life insurance companies and find the
best policy for you
it takes just two minutes to get the
quote and if you don't know the first
thing about insurance they've got all
the tools to get you up to speed
learning the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need be sure you're making
the right decision in fact over 4
million people have used policy genius
to shop for insurance policy genius
doesn't just do life insurance by the
way they also do health insurance and
disability insurance and auto insurance
shopping around saves you money
that's what policy genius helps you do
policy genius calm gets your search
search started in just two minutes you
can compare those quotes and make an
informed decision policy genius is
indeed the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance go check them out right
now at policy genius calm and they'll
give you all the information that you
need to know about insurance and then
you can go buy it so go check it out
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy a life insurance policy genius
calm alright so the latest breaking news
is that the authorities have arrested
the suspect in all of the attempted
bombings of various Democrats and
Democratic public figures I'm not gonna
say the name of the bomber because we
have a policy on the show that we don't
actually say the name of mass shooters
I'm going to extend that to bombers as
well specifically because so many folks
who are crazy actually like the
publicity that is attached to the naming
of bombers now we see the mass shooters
this is also true of people who attempt
to commit terror attacks one of their
goals is to assure publicity for
themselves and
incentivizing people to do evil things
because they want publicity is not
something we're going to do I will give
you the information about the guy but
I'm not gonna give you his name so the
guy's 56 years old he's identified as a
Native American Trump supporter now this
is why it was so stupid for so many on
the right to immediately leap to false
flag and I don't mean asking questions
I mean leaping to false flag you know
suggesting without any evidence that
this must be a false flag attack that
this must be some sort of democratic
operation the most obvious explanation
for a person sending a bunch of bombs to
highly public officials is that this is
a crazy person and as it turns out the
person is indeed a crazy person online
records show that this guy has a
criminal record and he has owned
companies called Native American
catering and vending as well as proud
Native America one low price
dry-cleaning he's a bodybuilder and he
is said to have been traced by DNA and
phone records and was flagged as a
suspect after making previous terror
threats to judges so presumably this is
all president Trump's and false photos
have emerged from a van that links this
guy to pro Trump anti Hillary Clinton
stickers here's what the pictures look
like for those who can't see the van is
plastered plastered with pro Trump
material it's just a bizarre van like if
you saw this on the street you would
figure absolutely crazy person there's
an inverse proportion between the number
of the between the number of bumper
stickers on your car and your sanity the
more bumper stickers on your car the
more clearly we can assume that you're a
crazy person so that means that this guy
is a complete nutjob obviously if you
just saw his van you would say the guy's
a complete nutjob
you wouldn't to know anything else about
him and then it's also the craziest
bumper stickers so it's not just CNN
sucks at bumper stickers it's pictures
of President Trump and Mike Pence it is
Hillary Clinton with a target over her
face it's the same thing with Van Jones
with the target over his face it's the
meme of President Trump riding a tank
with explosions in the background
there's a there's a bumper sticker
around here that says top youth soccer
recruits for Trump which I don't even
know what the hell that's supposed to
mean I mean I always could have figured
that it would be a soccer supporter who
is going to be responsible for something
like this
shocker I can't believe that somebody
with this van is is sending bombs to
people that's crazy now the media
immediately jump exactly where you think
they would jump which is the guy isn't
crazy he was a perfectly rational
until President Trump came along
unfortunately for them this is belied by
all available evidence so this person
has been arrested some ten times he was
arrested back in 2002 for an attempted
bombing threat presumably I guess that
was president Trump's fault back when he
was on the apprentice or something
that's the take of the media today law
enforcement officials covered that white
van it was covered in photos as I say of
Donald Trump and Mike Pence and had at
least one sticker referring to Hillary
Clinton here is a little bit of tape
from CBS News covering all of this the
FBI covering the van so all of that is
just a van it looks like in the same
location where there an arrest was made
or at least there's a lot of activity
and and I wonder you know what's
interesting
I'm guys and again I'm sorry Mel and and
sorry I'm just noticing that they're cut
the FBI the picture that you're looking
at right now is absolutely unbelievable
what they're doing is they're covering
up this van which I caught a very brief
glimpse of it and I can you know without
100% certainty but I thought I saw a
picture of Hillary Clinton in it on the
median are so excited I mean listen to
how the media are covering this
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo
the fan has pictures of Hillary and
friendly pictures of Trump and you know
what that means that means President
Trump is responsive he deputized this
man and that's what we're gonna get
we're gonna get for it now from here
till the election we're gonna get
president Trump's rhetoric is what
caused a crazy person to be crazy so
let's just remember Beck one year ago
like a little bit over a year ago a
Bernie Sanders supporter went and
legitimately shot shot at dozens of
Republican Congress people and nearly
killed the House Majority Whip Steve
Scalise shot him so badly he was in
critical condition when he did he
arrives shouting that because the
Republicans were killing people with
their health care plan that he was now
going to kill Republican Congress people
Bernie Sanders had spent the prior month
saying that the Republican healthcare
plans was going to actually kill people
this is something that Bernie Sanders
said with Bernie Sanders responsible for
the crazy guy no Bernie Sanders was not
responsible for the crazy guy now if you
want to say if somebody let's say that a
president Trump supporter went and just
punched a protester I would say okay
what closer linkage between the rhetoric
President Trump has used and that
particular action just as I say there's
a lot closer language to linkage between
Maxine Waters saying confront people in
with places and Democrats going and
confronting people in public places
incitements one activity is not
necessarily incitement to sending bombs
in the mail or shooting people up on a
congressional baseball field but the
media have left to a particular
conclusion Bernie Sanders in 2017 was
completely innocent of what this guy did
agree and then they say well a crazy
person like an obvious crazy person
it is president Trump's responsibility
what happened here and that is
absolutely a bunch of crap and it's
dangerous crap too it is because here's
what the left says blood says is the
climate of polarization the climate has
gotten too nasty in this country it's
just a bad nasty climate of polarization
that we have here in the United States
and that's all president Trump's fault
so maybe we got a sensor what people on
the right are saying maybe we oughta
claim that people on the right are
uniquely evil do they understand that
that claim actually radicalizes folks
that the best thing if they were if they
were two-sided about this if they were
objective about this if what they said
was listen everybody needs to tone down
the rhetoric Bernie Sanders needs to
tone down the rhetoric Democrats need to
tone down the rhetoric Republicans need
to tone down the rhetoric then at least
they're consistent I've been saying that
I've been saying that for literally
years on this program I've been saying
that but that's not what the media are
saying what the media are saying is that
every time a democratic whack job does
something it's the fault of Democratic
whack job every time a Republican whack
job does something it's the fault of all
Republicans across the country and that
is going to drive people nuts and it's
going to make people less likely to tone
down the rhetoric it's likely to make
more people anti-media and all of this
talk about radicalizing people against
the media the media don't need president
Trump's help for that they do it pretty
well themselves that doesn't mean the
president Trump ought to be saying what
he's saying it does mean that the
Democrats in the media are absolutely
radicalizing a population of people on
the other side by claiming falsely that
everyone on the other side is
responsible for the actions of somebody
who's clearly insane this stuff is
really really gross and the media we're
doing this in advance right they were
prepping this this narrative for
legitimately days in advance of the
actual discovery here we'll get to the
Republicans and what they did wrong here
- because President Trump's response to
this was really really idiotic but let
me just show you some of the CNN
Chiron's
that were preemptively attacking
President Trump when they didn't even
know who this guy was so this was from
yesterday and the host is standing in
front of a
a screen that says manhunt for serial
bomber and then it has profiles of the
various people who had bombs sends them
Eric Holder Maxine Waters Robertson hero
Joe Biden and then underneath here's
what the chyron says manhunt for serial
bomber going after Trump's targets the
idea here is that President Trump
somehow deputized this crazy person to
send bombs in the mail that was
president Trump's doing a CNN was saying
this openly they weren't trying to hide
the ball here
here's another Chiron okay that is a
reporter on screen from the White House
and it says underneath CNN Trump has no
plans to claim any personal
responsibility for inciting serial
bomber why would he have plans to claim
personal responsibility for inciting a
serial bomber to Bernie Sanders claimed
that he had responsibility for inciting
a serial shooter is there like really is
there any evidence that President Trump
incited this guy did he send a piece of
mail to this guy saying you know it
would be awesome can you send some pipe
bombs to Maxine Waters but this is
exactly what CNN was claiming and you
wonder why folks on the right don't
trust the media this is why folks on the
right don't trust the media I think it's
just it's absurd
here's Maxine Waters a person who
legitimately has said in the past few
months that you should get in people's
face in quasi violent ways in public
places on politics and now she's ripping
into President Trump and saying he
should take responsibility for an
obviously crazy person by the way this
is why I objected to all the false flag
garbage that so many on the right were
spewing right out of the gate because my
feeling is that the obvious answer to
this was it was a crazy person you know
who sends bombs to people in the mail
high-profile people in the mail bombs
that don't work properly you know who
does that
crazy people if I hears Maxine Waters
bleeding president from Maxine Waters
probably the most volatile and the most
violent rhetoric using Democrat in the
United States Congress here she is
blaming Trump for all of us I think the
President of the United States has been
dog whistling to his constituency making
them believe that their problems are
caused by those people over there and I
think that they're acting out what they
believe the president wants them to do
and the way that he wants them to act
okay that's crazy okay the idea that
Trump wants people to send bombs in the
mail is insane but that's totally what
Maxine water
would say you would expect her to say
this and it's this sort of one-sided
coverage that leaves people not to trust
the media now the media are not
responsible for people sending bonds to
them but the media are responsible for
increasing a volatile climate they blame
President Trump for increasing the
volatile climate I agree President Trump
certainly has not tempted down the
volatile climate but the media are part
of that volatile climate and they are
making the climate more volatile not
less volatile and the fact that they are
denying that demonstrates that they are
completely out of touch with reality I
have more on that plus more information
on the on the suspect on the alleged
bomber in just one second first let's
talk about you getting dressed up this
weekend so yeah we're already at the
weekend and that means that it's time
for you to get dressed up look snazzy
well the suit that you got off the rack
it doesn't look very good okay it's just
hanging off of you like drapes instead
you ought to be going and getting a nice
tailored suit go check it out at Indo
Chino Indo Chino is the world's most
exciting made-to-measure menswear
company they make suits in shirts your
exact measurements for an unparalleled
fit and comfort dudes love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
colors to choose from you can
personalize all of the details your
lapel lining pockets buttons writing
your own monogram all you have to do is
visit a stylist at their showroom and
have them take your measurements
personally they have those showrooms
around the country or you can measure at
home and shop online and Enzo Chino com
it's really cool and you feel like James
Bond it just comes right in the mail and
it fits like a glove
plus they have now moved into casual
clothing as well they sell chinos now
chinos originated 120 years ago as part
of a British French military uniform
they were designed to be simple and
durable and comfortable in camouflage
and earthy tones
well now Indo chinos are perfectly
tailored for a fit and customizable to
suit any personal taste and style right
now my listeners get any premium Indo
Chino suit for just 359 bucks at Indo
Chino comm when entering promo code
Shapiro at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price Indo chinos had an
introductory price of 79 bucks to
shipping is free Indo Chino comm promo
code Shapiro you get all those special
deals any premium suit for just 359
bucks plus free shipping and endo chinos
had an introductory price of 79 bucks
pretty solid deals for some of the best
looking clothes you're ever gonna wear
ok so new details on I mean the stuff is
emerging minute-by-minute new details on
the alleged bomber again we're not using
his name on the program for reasons I
specified a few minutes ago apparently
his Facebook and Twitter profile are
filled with crazy conspiracy theory
no I'm shocked clearly it's Trump's
fault the Facebook account is almost
exclusively proach from content
including pictures and videos
purportedly filmed at one of the
president's political rallies the
twitter feed is littered with far-right
conspiracy theories or violent threats
aimed at some of the president Trump's
most outspoken critics he appears to
have repeatedly tweeted about George
Soros at one point he purportedly wrote
you will vanish in a tweet aimed at the
billionaire Soros is one of the people
who received one of the bombs other
tweets falsely claimed that the Stoneman
Douglas high school shooting was a false
flag operation orchestrated by Soros and
his lip and his liberal allies the
account also posted frequently angry
messages at debbie Wasserman Schultz her
name was listed on the return account
for all of the bombs other prominent
liberal activists including David Hodges
Parkland survivor and Colin Kaepernick
and aunt Eva are targeted in other
tweets also this person tweeted violent
death threats and pictures of death at
Sarah Jean who's the New York Times
columnist who was who tweeted a bunch of
racist anti white stuff awhile ago
he also sends a gory image of a
beheading vote the comedian Jim Carrey
so in other words this is an insane
person this is a totally insane person
and how do we know he's insane well
besides the fact that his van is covered
in bumper stickers like a crazy person
the Florida man has a significant
criminal history and was previously
charged with making a bomb print in 2002
the ruling in that case was not
immediately clear on Friday he was also
convicted of theft in 2014 and 2013 and
battery in 2013 in 2012 he filed for
bankruptcy and declared in court filings
he lived with his mother so yeah clearly
this is president Trump's fault
obviously this is this is all President
Trump his Twitter feed is gross he's a
gross person i I can't believe it
just a shock but again the fact that he
is nuts is not going to stop the
Democrats from trotting out the lie that
it's Republicans who caused all this so
Joy Behar is doing this routine too she
did this preemptively she said that the
entire GOP is to blame for a crazy
person who lived with his mother and was
arrested for bomb threats sixteen years
ago and then arrested a bunch of times
in the past five years including many
times before Trump was president the
entire GOP is responsible for this and I
think that it's incumbent upon the
Republicans in this country to start to
speak out they did not open their mouths
when they he attacked your father they
did not open their mouths when he
attacked a gold star family
he said he was gonna grab women by their
genitals or when he said the Second
Amendment will take care of Hillary
Clinton they stayed silent and they are
the perpetrators all sigh okay what's
amazing is that when Democrats are
actually reminded of violent rhetoric
used by Democrats in the past then they
get very very angry and this is the part
where the one-sidedness of the media is
creating a more volatile political
climate so let's take for example Katy
Turk a detour over at MSNBC obviously a
member of the left and Katy tour was
reminded by a guest about some of the
violent rhetoric used by Democrats in
recent weeks she didn't like it she
wasn't willing to talk about it Eric
Erickson is the guy you'll hear talking
about Democratic rhetoric but MSNBC will
have none of it because obviously only
one side of the political aisle is bad
and volatile and uses overheated
rhetoric politician other than Donald
Trump say I'm so proud or give a kudos
to another politician who body-slammed a
reporter have you ever heard that from
anybody else other than Donald Trump
well in Katy this question hold on Donna
have you Donald Trump is a is a symptom
of what's going on in this country your
your blood pressure going up over Donald
Trump right now as he advocates violence
okay the answer is no it's terrible
right no it's terrible when president
from says that stuff also it is terrible
when Democrats say that you should kick
people when they say that you should
confront people in public places when
Bernie Sanders claims that Republicans
are going to kill millions of people
with their health care plan when many
when a vast swath of the Democratic
Party claimed the tea partiers were
actual terrorists to pretend that the
volatile political climate in the United
States is anything it was ridiculous but
this has been a long-standing Democratic
tactic for legitimately decades I mean
after JFK was shot in 1963 Democrats
tried to claim that it was right-wing
rhetoric that it killed JFK even though
it turns out that it was a commie so
there there's nothing new Under the Sun
but it's increasingly frustrating and
this actually is dangerous for the
country for two reasons not just well
and believe me I'm gonna get to what the
Republicans had to say about this in
just a second including President Trump
issuing an asinine tweet this morning
but what is dangerous about the media's
take on this is when they suggest that
rhetoric that does not incite violence
is respond
for violence they are criminalizing
rhetoric and when they do it for only
one side it appears that they only want
to criminalize rhetoric on one side
which leads people to believe that they
are coming for you it leads to a feeling
of threat and to fail to acknowledge
this is to fail to acknowledge what's
driving a lot of our politics these days
which is a reactionary feel that the
other side is threatening you and it's
present on both sides now let's get to
the right-wing response to all of this
preemptively so there are people on the
right I think most people on the right
who said listen we need to wait for more
information here we don't know who did
this the most likely outcome is crazy
person and I said this repeatedly I said
if you think this is a false flag attack
or you jump to the conclusions a false
flag attack based on nothing but
confirmation bias you're doing it wrong
I've been saying that repeatedly over
and over on this show I've set it on
Twitter I had to set it in my columns
okay so I think most people on the right
sort of agreed with that but there was a
substantial substratum on the right that
suggested that this had to be a Democrat
it had to be somebody on the left who
perpetrated this because obviously it
was too convenient for Democrats in the
run-up to the election this sort of
conspiracy theorizing is not good either
the reason that it is not good either is
because it allows people to believe that
there are no crazies on their own side
that evil is entirely relegated to
people who disagree with them it leads
to more polarization and again it's not
good for the country when you jump to
conclusions based on your own
confirmation bias and right now there's
tremendous incentive to do just that
there's not incentive for people to say
let's wait for more information let's
wait for more information is one of the
least popular sentences in American
politics and it's usually right it's
almost always right but it's the least
popular phrase because if you jump to a
conclusion and that jump it ends up
being right your site says ha that guy
gets it you know how you know he gets it
cuz his gut was right he gets it and if
you're wrong your own sites as well his
gut was right it's just that the facts
didn't fit his gut in this case but he
still knows what's what so jumping to
conclusions is being incentivized on
every side right now and it's really bad
it's particularly now when the President
of the United States does it so
legitimately legitimately just a couple
of hours before the FBI arrested the
suspect presidents from started tweeting
about the bomb stuff this morning so he
tweeted out about CNN funny highly rated
CNN and others can criticize me
even blaming me for the currents made of
bombs and ridiculously comparing this to
September 11th and the Oklahoma City
bombing and when I criticized them they
go wild and scream it's just not
presidential he's right about that one
okay president Trump is correct about
that one when he says the media rip him
and they criticize him it will and when
he were when he responds they say it's
like September 11th or Oklahoma City and
that he's and he's creating that he's
not wrong about that but here's what
President Trump does go wrong so he
can't just stop there
at 7:19 a.m. he tweets out Republicans
are doing so well in early voting and at
the polls and now this quote-unquote
bomb stuff happens and the momentum
greatly slows news not talking politics
very unfortunate what is going on
Republicans go out and vote mr.
president this is stupid
this is stupid and this is immoral okay
the problem with people sending bombs in
the mail is not the impact on voting
it's people sending bombs in the mail
and the suggestion that this is all just
a misdirect by the media when people
send bombs in the mail to a bunch of
prominent Democratic figures no it is
not and when you lend credence to
conspiracy theories all you are doing is
fueling the flames of the volatility
everyone's okay so basic bottom line of
the show a lot of people suck right now
here's how you cannot suck in just one
second I'm gonna explain how you can not
be one of the people who suck okay I'm
gonna explain in just one second first
let's talk about keeping your online
information safe whether you're in a
cafe or a hotel we often rely on public
Wi-Fi to use the internet on the go but
something as simple as paying your bills
online from a Starbucks can leave your
data exposed a hacker could easily
intercept that information steal
passwords credit card numbers this is
why you need a VPN and the software I
use to protect my online activity from
spies and data thieves
that's called Express VPN expressvpn has
easy to use apps that run seamlessly in
the background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures and anonymizes
my internet browsing they encrypt my
data they hide my public IP address and
you should use it every time you go
online Express VPN cost less than seven
bucks a month
it comes with a 30-day money-back
guarantee to take back that Internet
privacy today and find out how I can get
three months for free go to expressvpn
calm
slash man that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
man for three months free with a
one-year package but expressvpn secure
your internet right now visit expressvpn
com
/ Ben to learn more again that's
expressvpn comm / Ben there is a reason
that expressvpn is the most highly
recommended expressvpn VPN services
they're just terrific go check them out
expressvpn comm / Ben to get three
months for free with a one-year package
already so here's how you cannot suck
okay a few rules for not sucking at this
one when there's not enough information
instead of you touting out your
speculation or your jump to conclusion
just wait because within 48 hours there
will be enough information and then you
can make a judgement - don't attribute
crazy people to your political opponents
they attributes your political opponents
what is attributable do not attribute to
them that which is not attributable so
if you want to attribute mobs going and
shouting Ted Cruz out of restaurants to
Maxine Waters that seems reasonable to
me if you want to accuse President Trump
of incentivizing people to punch
protesters I think even that is maybe
reasonable but if you're going to claim
the president Trump is responsible for
mail bombs and you're getting a claim
that Bernie Sanders is responsible for
shootings on congressional baseball
fields that is not reasonable fourth if
you are going to start attributing the
heightened political rhetoric in this
country to violence if you're gonna
start saying violence is coming from
that then you're going to have to
recognize that this sort of heightened
political rhetoric exists on all sides
okay because if you don't then you are
lying you're being dishonest hey you are
now I'm not saying that it's happening
equally on all sides but I am saying
that it is happening on all sides and we
all need to take it down a pitch okay
president Trump's political rhetoric is
a problem when he says that I mean I
criticized him heavily last week on the
show for praising Greg John forté for
body slamming a reporter if you're gonna
do that you also have to point out when
Democrats use violent rhetoric which
they have been doing more and more often
Hillary Clinton said two weeks ago that
civility against Republicans civility
with Republicans was simply uncalled for
at this time if we are going to talk
about heightened political rhetoric we
have to talk about it in an accurate way
we are not doing that and the media are
not doing that and that's creating
blowback against the media okay finally
here's how you can here's how you can
really not suck at all of this start to
start to think about whether the stuff
that you say is more likely to raise the
temperature or lower the temperature and
if it is raising the temperature maybe
you should think about whether
it's appropriate to raise the
temperature sometimes it is sometimes
it's not but this is a mistake
okay this is a mistake to simply raise
the temperature at will and then be
surprised when the when the temperature
is raised it's it's you know I I'm I'm
hoping that the country somehow comes
back to its senses here but I feared
that that's not going to happen I fear
that the media are going to rip all
Republicans for this sort of activity
Republicans are going to simply claim
false flag or simply going to blame
Democrats for similar sort of activity
and then we get a cycle that spins down
into garbage from here until the end of
time that doesn't have to happen that
doesn't have to happen crazy people do
crazy things separately amoral rhetoric
is immoral thirdly not all immoral
rhetoric incentivizes violence and
fourthly maybe we should tone down the
immoral rhetoric regardless as to
whether it incentivizes violence we do
all those things we can have a country
if not then we are in serious serious
trouble now speaking of nonsense that's
being pushed by the press the the press
coverage of the caravan is is really
quite astonishing
so NBC News I mean speaking of media
bias when President Trump rips into
media bias and then folks in the media
say there's no such thing as media bias
how dare he attack the media NBC News
made their header on Twitter an actual
picture an actual picture of the caravan
of the migrant caravan that is simply
propaganda that is not news that is
propaganda that is these are victims
these are people who are approaching the
border and this is president Trump's
fault that's why NBC News does that the
polarizing political environment did not
begin with Trump at wilmot and with
Trump it is going to continue from here
till the end of time hey and then you
see the rhetoric on the caravan issue
obviously being being exaggerated on
both sides so here was President Trump
tweeting about the caravan issue
yesterday and I'll explain what's wrong
with this because when I first read the
tweet I didn't really know it was wrong
with it and then I looked into it a
little more and there's a problem with
the tweet in sort of effect it's correct
but in but in practice it's wrong so
President Trump tweeted out to those in
the caravan turn around we are not
letting people into the United States
illegally go back to your country and if
you want apply for a citizenship like
millions of others are doing so people
pointed out that the people who are
trying to get to the southern border of
the United States are applying for
asylum you can't do that unless
already in the United States or at the
US border so you can't actually apply
for political asylum from the country of
origin however president Trump's actual
suggestion is that these people are not
actually looking for political asylum
instead they're looking for economic
opportunity which means that they would
be fraudulently filing papers if they
were seeking political asylum when they
were really looking for economic
opportunity so go home and apply the
right way I don't think there's anything
wrong with Trump saying go home and
apply the right way but if the idea is
that it's illegal for them to approach
the southern border and apply for asylum
that of course is not true either
what is also not true is that the United
States has an obligation to take in
everyone who wants to cross the border
no matter what where they come from or
what their motivation is John Kasich is
back I don't know why oh god no please
God no not John Kasich John Kasich Ohio
Governor he's back and he says that guy
he's spoken to God now as a religious
person who speaks with God three times a
day guy doesn't talk back to me but I
talk to God fairly often like a lot okay
but apparently God does talk to John
Kasich and it's funny how the left will
mock Mike Pence when he says that he has
to pray on things in order to make a
decision
but when John Kasich is mouthing leftist
platitudes in the name of God then it's
totally fine here's John Kasich
suggesting that God doesn't want us
opposing the caravan and let's stop
putting up walls around ourselves and
not understanding the plight the trouble
and the problems of others it is not
right and the Lord doesn't want it and
our people at their hearts want to reach
out to others look at what they do in
these storms they go and they rescue
people they don't know they put them in
their homes they feed them that's
America not all this garbage and this
division and yelling and screaming and
hatred on all sides okay well it is also
true that what does America is
maintaining a border so there's that as
well but even John Kasich right the guy
who's gonna bring us all together can't
stop himself from using this sort of
overheated rhetoric it's it's a problem
it's a problem okay so meanwhile
speaking of overheated rhetoric megyn
kelly is gonna be out at NBC she's out
at NBC because they are basically
fibbing about megyn kelly being a racist
so this was sort of predictable megyn
kelly was not getting good ratings in
morning and so they decided that they
wanted to dump her and then they found
an excuse to dump her when she said on a
morning show that she didn't see
what was wrong with people darkening
their skin for Halloween costumes they
accused her of being Pro blackface as
we've discussed over the last couple of
days
this was sheer absolute nonsense it is
just untrue we'll talk about the media's
attempt to polarize the culture on the
issue of race and NBC's attempt to do so
for political gain in just one second
but you're gonna have to go to daily
wire calm and subscribe to be part of
that $9.99 a month got to subscription
to daily wire when you do you get the
rest of this show live the rest of the
under Clavin show live the rest of
Michael Noel's show live you get to be
part of our mailbag which we are doing
today can send us questions in live
today I'm sure you have questions for
which we have the answers also when you
spend $99 a year when you get the annual
which is cheaper than the monthly you
get this the leftist here is hot or cold
tumblr it is magnificent
you will love it you will live it you
will lavish yourself upon it it's
fantastic man it's it's so good and the
leftist cheers hot or cold tumblr so go
check that out right now also check out
our Sunday special this weekend you do
that by subscribing at iTunes and
leaving us a review for 5 stars those
are the only sorts of reviews accepted
at this at this purchase Center so go
over there and check that out next week
Sunday special by the way is epic it's
really really good so go check that out
as well we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so folks are willing to polarize
political rhetoric for even tiny gains
right now on every issue and that's the
real problem you know folks are blaming
President Trump for the bombing today
for the attempted bombings
Tom Nichols is one of the people who is
doing that so Tom Nichols has a whole
Twitter thread he's an anti Trump
Republican and here's what he tweeted
out and I'm going to explain why I think
that this misses the point he says the
question isn't whether magev an guy is
nuts since he clearly is that's not the
president's fault the better question is
whether the White House and the Trump
media complex is pushing the crazy juice
so hard it's making unstable people more
likely to be violent I've said many
times the lone wolf guys who pledged to
Isis or to white supremacy or to
anti-abortion violence are kook's went
looking for a cause they have to go find
the propaganda and when they do they
mainline it the difference here is that
really hateful stuff is coming in waves
not from foreigners or fringe groups but
from White House sponsored rallies from
widely cited internet sites that have
zillions of followers and from a
four-hour window of hot/crazy known as
Fox in primetime which is very
convenient for Tom Nichols he says no
one in politics or win nut media made
this guy send bombs period what they did
instead was superheat the political
environment and flood crazy BS into the
information space so regularly that
unhinge unhinged guys like this think
they're being patriots by spit by
sending bombs okay let's assume that's
true let's assume that when you heat up
the political water that more frogs jump
out of the pot let's assume that that's
the case yeah let's let's assume that
well wouldn't the same hold true on the
left when they overheat the political
rhetoric when they say for example that
megyn kelly is an absolute racist when
they say that anybody who even mentions
Halloween costumes is so racist that
they cannot be employed and when it the
same and like Kirsten powers has a piece
today about how megyn kelly is a racist
because she is white she's megyn kelly
said something really racist should not
be a surprising sentence to anyone the
original sin was that Kelly was hired by
NBC at all Kelly had a long track record
of racial demagoguery at Fox before she
ever set foot at the NBC Studios okay so
now again is this heating up the
political system I think it is I think
it is how about this op-ed from George
Yancey a professor of philosophy at
Emory University which obviously needs a
better philosophy department he has a
piece today called hashtag I am sexist
he says it's time we men take risk
ability for our role in the problem of
violence against women he says that all
men are guilty of violence against women
he says I've decided not to cut corners
join me with due diligence and civic
duty and publicly proclaim I am sexist
in fact perhaps it is time we lay claim
to a movement I am sexist think about
its national and international
implications as we take responsibility
for our sexism our misogyny our
patriarchy it's hard to admit we are
sexist I for instance would like to
think that I possess a genuine feminist
bona fides bona fide ease but Who am I
kidding I'm a failed and broken feminist
more pointedly I am sexist there are
times when I fear for the loss of my own
entitlement as a male toxic masculinity
takes many forms
all forms continue to hurt and to
violate women for example before I got
married I insisted my wife take my last
name after all she was to become my wife
so why not take my name and become part
of me she refused she wanted to keep her
own last name I was not happy especially
as she had her father's last name which
I argued contradicted her position
against patriarchy but as she argued
this is my name and it is part of my
identity I became stubborn and
interpreted her decision as evidence of
a lack of full commitment to me well she
brilliantly proposed that we both change
our last names and take on a new name
together showing our commitment to each
other
yeah so obviously this guy is a real
anti-feminist he's a terror he says if
you're a woman reading this I have
failed you I mean it's like a Maoist
forced apology and it sounds like a P
owt through my silence in a nun
interrogating collective misogyny I have
failed you I have helped and continue to
help perpetuate sexism I know about how
we hold on to forms of power that
dehumanize you only to elevate our sense
of masculinity I recognize my silence as
an act of violence and for this I
sincerely apologize then really what
he's doing is he's saying I'm not a
sexist because I'm apologizing for my
sexism but every other male is a sexist
is that superheating the rhetoric is
that polarizing our society maybe just a
little bit and let's point out the media
hypocrisy when it comes to these sorts
of issues when it comes to these sorts
of issues every democratic male is
considered a non sexist in reality when
it comes to when it comes to the media
megyn kelly happens to be a person
right-of-center
hey Jimmy Kimmel is a person
left-of-center has anyone brought up the
fact that if we're gonna talk about
blackface Jimmy Kimmel in 2000 did an
actual blackface routine on national
television on Comedy Central this is
Jimmy Kimmel in in
black-faced not only mocking black
people he's mocking Karl Malone
specifically mocking Karl Malone for not
being able to speak English properly
this is a lot closer to insulting black
people than megyn kelly saying I don't
mind if someone dresses up in darkens
their skin as Diana Ross to honor as I
Anna Ross hey Jimmy Kimmel somehow has a
show on ABC no problem here's Jimmy
Kimmel circa 2000 tall below look up and
sky and say what the hell going on up
there
UFO live on another planet born and
whole like et comma Lowell read on TV
about white people getting deducted by
alien sticking all kind of hell up day
but and that's a damn thing this is
enough bTW you better stay the hell back
is that a problem apparently that wasn't
a problem for Jimmy Kimmel but it's a
serious problem for Megan Kelly to
suggest that dressing up as a black
person to honor a black person is is not
that bad she actually has to lose her
job over it right they that are gonna
pay her out but she has to lose her job
over again the polarizing environment
predated President Trump it will it will
go far beyond President Trump because
that is the that is the nature of the
politics that we have chosen and it's
the nature of a politics that the left
continues to push to its most radical
extreme there's an opinion piece in
today's New York Times that is fully
anti science it is completely crazy and
yet this is now being touted as not only
mainstream but if you don't believe it
then you are apparently a bigot the
piece is by dr. fausto-sterling a
professor of biology and Gender Studies
so professor of something useful and a
professor of something completely
useless the piece is called why sex is
not binary the complexity is more than
cultural its biological - so what does
dr. fausto-sterling stay doctor
fausto-sterling points out that there
are genetic sexual disorders right that
make people intersex for example and she
therefore suggests that because there
are intersex people there is not sexual
dimorphism in human biology this is
crazy talk okay it's just crazy talk
she cites a bunch of ridiculous honestly
ridiculous references I think this is my
favorite just because I happen to know
something about this she talks about
Jewish thought she says the ancient
Jewish rabbinical code known as the two
septa for example sometimes treated
people who had male and female parts as
women they could not inherit
or service priests at other times as men
forbidding them from shaving or being
secluded with women so supposedly this
means that it was a third gender no you
don't okay as someone who actually knows
this stuff I will tell you exactly what
the Jewish law was doing the Jewish law
was saying this person has two separate
sets of genitals
we don't know whether they're a male or
a female therefore we are going to be as
strict as possible in every circumstance
so we'll treat them as female for
purposes of forbidding them from temple
service but we will treat them as male
for purposes of forbidding them from
shaving in other words we don't know but
that doesn't mean male and female don't
exist the case being made in the pages
of the New York Times and I asked my
wife about this cuz she's a doctor guys
and that means and so I asked her like
is there any like what does this mean
she says no this is a person trying to
cast genetic disorders as the norm it's
like saying that if somebody is born
with spina bifida and therefore has a
level of paralysis in their legs this
means that human beings are not
two-legged walking creatures you don't
change the definition of human being
based on people who have certain genetic
conditions and you don't change the
nature of male and female based on
people who have certain genetic
conditions does that polarize the
culture to do that and then claim
everyone who disagrees is some sort of
bigot yes it does
yes it does yeah that's exactly where we
are that's exactly where okay let's get
to the mailbag because this has been a
very tiring week and maybe some people
in the mailbag can cheer me up so let's
check it out all right let's start with
Jesse Jesse says dear Ben I read brave
new world last year and found it to be
hilarious what are your thoughts on it
and what are some other books that point
out the flaws in left yes leftist
ideology you would recommend
well brave new world is actually a very
prescient take on what exactly a
Technology Center hedonistic society
would look like then the the basic
premise of brave new world is that
there's a group of people who have
basically separated sex and procreation
that they are drugged to be happy with
the drug called soma that they are they
they're emotionally manipulated be happy
and then there are these group of
primitives who sort of live out in the
middle of nowhere as people used to the
question of brave new world really is
whether the brave new world is good or
whether it's bad it's pretty obvious
that it's bad for people who live in
Western civilization which means you
have to ask yourself why as far as other
books along those lines obviously the
works of George Orwell are along these
lines Animal Farm in 1984 there's a
precursor to 1984 it's a Russian novel
and I'm forgetting the name of it it's
also very good there's a bunch of
fiction science fiction that sort of
along the lines of brave new world
post-apocalyptic fiction obviously desam
that's actually a book I recommended
this week submission is sort of along
these lines a parodic take on what is
happening in Europe I mean the
unrecovered story of the of the year is
that the European Human Rights
Commission ruled today they ruled today
that it is proper to find someone for
speaking against the Prophet Mohammed in
Europe okay that is that is indeed a
brave new world Tyler says hey Ben
I was curious if you're going to be on a
strict parent a strict parent on who
your children date when they are older
or are you gonna let your kids date or
marry whoever they want huge fan of the
show of course Mubeen strict parent I'm
not an idiot you think that I'm gonna
let my kids date whoever they want kids
are stupid why would I possibly do that
first of all my kids don't get to date
until they're of marital age because I
am not in favor of dating just for fun I
think that that is a temptation to to
sin and I think that it is a like I
don't think that you get anything out of
it when you're 16 years old they can
date when they're ready to get married
because dating is supposed to be for
marriage it's not supposed to be for
heavy petting or going riding in the car
or any of that stupidity okay Spencer
says hey Ben what are your thoughts on
the works of modern Jewish philosophers
such as Martin Buber Emmanuel Levinas
and Hannah Arendt well I mean you'd have
to Boober is the closest to an actual
Jewish philosopher I don't know the word
workable of mine is that well so I'm
gonna leave him out Hana Arendt is not
particularly a Jewish philosopher she's
more of a philosopher who happened to be
Jewish her connection to Judaism is
pretty strained Martin Buber may is the
the creator of sort of the I thou binary
he says that that religion is basically
a a conversation between the divine and
man I like a lot of that I don't like
his Nanta Zionism very much Jeffrey says
who do you think will run Republican in
2024 you know there are a lot of
candidates out there I would be
surprised if Rand Paul doesn't try to
make another run I would be surprised if
nikki Haley doesn't try to make a run in
2024 I'd be surprised in my pens doesn't
try to make a run in 2024 there are a
bunch of Republicans out there who
probably would timothy's had been do you
think the left actually believes their
own arguments I was wondering if you
could help explain the hatred of Jews
from the radical left yet they parade
around calling everyone else Nazis
thanks Tim well I think that most people
on the Left are sincere but I don't know
that they've really thought through
their own arguments
which is why I spend a lot of my time
when I talk to folks on the left trying
to get people on the left to recognize
the consequences of their own arguments
right what do they actually believe it
route and as far as anti-semitism on the
Left I've suggested that there are
really three main types of anti-semitism
in the world right now there's kind of
the alt-right anti-semitism which is
old-style
racial and religious anti-semitism Jews
are inferior or bad or corrupt or greedy
or Communists because they kill Jesus
and all of this kind of stuff that's
type number one and that's pretty
terrible in old school type number two
is Muslim anti-semitism radical Muslim
anti-semitism which sort of conflates
religious anti-semitism with ethnic
anti-semitism and you see that
throughout the world where hate crimes
against Jews are rising in Europe as the
radical Islamic population of Europe
Rises and third type of anti-semitism is
leftist anti-semitism where
anti-semitism arises for two reasons one
the secular left doesn't like religion
very much and to the secular left very
often believes that basic enjoy that
basic distribution of resources that is
not even means that the person who is
more prosperous somehow victimized the
person who's less prosperous Jews happen
to be more prosperous they tend to
achieve highly in intellectual areas the
State of Israel is a wealthy state and
so if folks look at that and they say
well they must have gotten wealthy by
screwing somebody else and therefore
they're the bad guys in this particular
situation also the State of Israel is a
nationalistic institution the left does
not like nationalism they think that
internationalism and globalism is a
better way of life I disagree brian says
who's your favorite comic book
supervillain and why thanks love the
show well they're they're a couple who
are just fantastic so the Joker is great
but only because the Joker is just sheer
chaos
Lex Luthor is fantastic because Lex
Luthor at least in the modern iteration
in under sort of Jeff Jones Lex Luthor
is taken as a character who is firmly
convinced that we cannot give power to
any one person or any one being because
if we do that person could use the power
against us which is actually the correct
premise it's actually Batman's premise
right Batman sort of uses the same
premise a lot in Batman vs Superman in
the comics that's really what Batman is
is saying he's saying we can't allow
anybody to have this sort of power if
they are going to you know be judging us
from above that
y-you have to believe that that the only
reason Superman is allowed to exist in
this world in the in comic book world is
because he is truth justice in the
American Way where he not he would be a
super villain right so I like Lex Luthor
a lot and magneto obviously is I'm not a
marvel fan particularly but magneto is a
terrific villain John says hey Ben
I've been married to my wife for over a
year now and I like most men who made
her more conservative over time well you
know I think that multum not sure that
men make the women more conservative
over time I think most likely marriage
and living in a in an institution where
you actually have to live with one other
person and be responsible that tends to
make people more conservative the one
issue she will not budge on however is
abortion I'm very cut and dry in it and
do not agree with abortion for any
reason other than if the mother's life
is in danger it seems every time we talk
about the issue an argument ensues you
have any advice on how to talk about the
issue and highlighting the negatives of
abortion without coming off as
condescending big fan well you know
honestly I don't think is about
condescension I think that it's more
about you have to look at the actual
biology of a growing human child and
this isn't really about my moral system
is better than your moral system it's
really about morality forbids the
killing of human beings this is a human
being that's what science says you don't
have to be condescending about that but
you know I'm not sure in what context
this would this would really come up I
know this when I first met my wife she
seemed to be a lot more pro-choice and
then as she learned more about the
biology she became more pretty she's
from probably more pro-life than I am at
this point so biology tends to be the
great leveler when it comes to this
particular issue okay final question Sam
says hey Ben my intellectual hero loved
everything you're doing question and
joke when scientists find life anywhere
sells bacteria on other planets or moons
and we all celebrate the greatest
achievement in human history will left
be consistent in their hypocrisy and
declare cells not a life but in the
other breath say they are the party of
science and recognize cells are life
making a new definition of what's life
once more
this is stupid and exhausting love the
shop well yeah I mean there's an
argument that I've made I made it on fox
news when I did my Sundays special you
know this argument that life does not
exist in single-celled organisms as long
as they're human but they exist
everywhere else that obviously is
logically untenable in every conceivable
way okay time for a quick thing that I
like and then some things that I hate so
thinking I like today so I decided to do
some cartoons end of the week
not only because cartoons have bombs in
them but also because
cartoons are hilarious and joyous and
fun and I think we've lost a lot of
those things so here is a little bit of
one of the great classical music
cartoons of all time this is Bugs Bunny
not being a transgender bunny but
pretending to be female for purposes of
deceiving Elmer Fudd Bugs Bunny was not
actually a female bunny in a male
Bunny's body
Hera's Bugs Bunny and Elmer Fudd in what
what's opera doc
[Music]
yes I know
my
when
inside
[Music]
let's go watch it
the animation in these cartoons is
really first-rate
and my favorite part of it is the vogner
Ian's horse the giant fat horse it's
just great and elmer fudd wearing the
viking helmet and the whole thing is
just it's terrific stuff so yeah yes
kids can watch this and it's it's really
funny stuff ok go check it out time for
enough of the joy let's go back to
hatred time for some things that I hate
so curt schilling was the hero of the
2004 Red Sox World Series team there was
a 300 that the New York Yankees had a
300 lead and in the American League
Championship Series and the Red Sox came
back from a 3o deficit I remember I was
in Boston at the time it was
unbelievable and the Red Sox came out
from a 300 deficit for the first time in
baseball history and they won the series
in game 6 Curt Schilling had been
injured and I believe Game three Game
two or Game three he'd been injured in
his ankle and they didn't know if he'd
be able to pitch again because his
velocity just dropped he had torn a
tendon in his ankle they invented a
surgery where they stapled the tendons
in his ankle down okay and then he went
any pitched Game six of the World Series
and he was gutting through actual
bleeding like you could he started
bleeding through his sock as he was
pitching so he was the hero of the world
of the of the Red Sox championship
season in 2004 well now the Red Sox are
in the World Series again and in the
first game they had a bunch of members
of the 2004 Red Sox team throw out the
first pitch together it was a lot of the
key members Curt Schilling was not
invited Curt Schilling was not invited
because Curt Schilling is right-wing and
the leadership team at the Red Sox is
left-wing he was the biggest star on
that team he was the reason they went to
the World Series he's the reason they
won the World Series but here was here
is Curt Schilling talking about that
yesterday politics and for you know we
talk sports that's the name of the show
and that's what we do and we're gonna
keep talking sports but the fact the
matter is politics has crept in starting
in a very significant way with Colin
Kaepernick and it's just continued and
and that's not gonna change but that's
not who we are what we do and and the
fact that matter as I said last night I
sleep pretty good at night I know
Who I am I know what I am and my rings
are still there and my trophies telling
the Shelf it's all good okay so alright
you know that obviously is ridiculous
but that is the length to which
polarization has gone Kurt's showing
forget about his political views the guy
was the hero of the 2004 team not
invited to the World Series just great
stuff okay other stupidity final
stupidity for the day and then we'll
leave for the week because I got to take
a break man
mathematicians this is according to real
clear investigations mathematicians who
want tenure at UCLA have to do more than
show a facility with numbers they have
to pledge in writing a commitment to
diversity equity and inclusivity all
professors applying for tenure-track
positions at UCLA must write a
statements on their commitment to
diversity showing for example their
record of success advising women and
minority graduate students according to
the UCLA office of equity diversity and
inclusion this reflects a push by
college bureaucrats to ratchet up
requirements to achieve a more diverse
campus this is so insane so instead of
the burden of proof being on somebody to
show that somebody's racist instead the
burden proof is on you to demonstrate
that you are not racist by signing a
forced statement under penalty of lack
of tenure showing that you are committed
to diversity now not diversity and
thought obviously diversity in ethnicity
now what's weird about that for science
and math departments is presumably you
want to recruit the best candidates
regardless of race and you know who is
most affected by all of the affirmative
action programs at top universities not
white folks Asian folks there's an
entire lawsuit against Harvard
University about that right now but
these universities have decided that
ideology matters I held a lot more than
actual efficacy of these departments and
that is not a call for lack of diversity
it's a call for a meritocracy which
matters a lot when you are talking
particularly about merit driven fields
like math and science but I guess that
we're not going to do that anymore we're
instead of gonna force people to sign
ridiculous Stalinist statements about
leftist priorities before we allow them
to teach math at a major university
solid job universities good job guys
okay well we'll be back here next week
we'll see how crazy things are then have
a safe have a safe weekend I believe I'm
supposed to be on Meet the Press on CBS
on Sunday is it Meet the Press which is
then what yeah I believe it's Meet the
Press so I will I would get the
information out and and I will let you
know I'll tweet out all of that in
on NBC it's NBC's Meet the Press I will
be on that on Sunday is the plan so make
sure to check that out and we'll see you
here next Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018